vina bluff c'est très simple il y a
derrière ce rideau déchirant des
personnages des choses vous allez lire
ce que vous voyez je dirai ce que je
vois et vous dirai ce que vous voyez
d'accord j'ai regardé je vais dire ce
que je vois vous dirai ce que vous voyez
et après on verra
j'avais regardé l'émission que je sais
ce que c'est tu vois ça non si tu aimes
pas peut-être pas ma gueule je peux plus
t'en question mais je sais je vous
mettais pas un peu plus voir si on va
pas c'est avant tout la mission la
journée n'a pas envie de se battre pour
finir journée alors moi je vois moi je
vois je vois là bas là tu vois surtout
tes fiches ça se voit non mais tu es
devenu un connard moi j'en ai barre toi
si tu veux construire
on sait par artistiquement on se sait
pas on se bat on peut pas se séparer à
justine jeu qu'on sépare est ses
participantes on est animé la même
émission cessé mardi alors et donc je
vois quoi toi bon alors c'est soit je
vois bernard montiel déguisé en saint
bernard à malte en artois facile
possible
ces balles et serait vénère d'être là
que porte
moi je vois vincent mcdoom qui caresse
des chiens très sensuellement seraient
pas d'accord vous pensez qu'il a raison
tel est le cas elle au journal michael
bradley il joue pas le bon moi je veux
on va dire ce que tu vois moi voir un
rideau de fer vous faites c'est que des
trucs avec des chiens et il n'ya pas
vincent mcdoom derrière le rideau mais
il y a vingt chiens mc do
regardez
une
c'est magnifique
j'ai perdu mon chien l'année dernière ça
me fait quelque chose on va faire de
notre cabine parce qu'on va par année
les candidats et peut-être j'ai pas bien
compris le principe de ce jeu fallait et
ben voilà on fait attention aux petits
et ben voila cyril hanouna a marché sur
un chien c'est pas évident c'est une
gouttière ne tenait qu'à chacun leur
tour ils veulent c'était toujours un
rapport qu'est ce que tu es alors moi
j'ai pas sûr on le voit jamais en arrêt
décennal qu'est ce que ça va ça vient
l'autre côté les chiens je vois françois
viaud qui boit un thé avec rintintin et
milou après ok tu vois c'est la route la
prochaine bah merci d'être passé mon
sens je vous rappelle jamin griveaux est
en train de faire une nouvelle vidéo
wimax avec la queue d'un chien tu vois
quand ils disent que tu vois ça tu vas
pas me croire mais je revois un rideau
témoin
je vois territoire n'a pas retenu ce
mois je vois le che luc hees et fille en
dessous du tube ça c'est une bonne
question ciel parce que les chapeaux
comme ça wily l'impôt c'est vrai qu'ils
bernard montiel mail au regard des clés
dans le tube
[Applaudissements]
il a les dents